so i'm
i am searching out the weirder stories
right so do you know who bud hopkins is
yeah so i
i worked with bud hopkins but hopkins
hypnotized me and really
yeah and and what was that like well
i'll tell you that in a second so when
talking with bud hopkins uh
uh tell tell for people who are
listening explain oh so bud hopkins bud
hopkins was a ufo abduction researcher
he used the term abduction he was not
shy about using the term abduction he's
a ufo abduction researcher
who wrote a series of books between like
the early 80s and i think the last one
was in 2011 or so it came out
he was an artist in new york city and he
took on the role of
researching ufo abduction and talking to
abductees
and documenting their their experiences
in books at the same time
everyone who worked with him will say he
was a thoughtful
sensitive caring person who was doing
two things he was researching a
complicated subject that's beyond belief
at the same time he was trying to offer
solace to the people who've had these
experiences
and he died in august 21 2011 which is
going to be the 10-year anniversary in
about a month now a little over a month
and and i know that date because my
birthday is the next day the august 22nd
so um talking to bud
he he's i said do you know
synchronicities and stuff like weird
stuff that surrounds these
these experiences and he kind of goes oh
yeah oh yeah
and he said like what do you make of
that he said well like he kind of he
kind of made this hand gesture he said
like
you know this stuff this stuff he kind
of made it like
like splashes everywhere like one event
like little stuff just goes everywhere
there's all this
outlying stuff and he said my it's my
job
as an author to try to rein that in
and and give you my information that
way and i realized years later
that like i'm the guy looking at those
little drops that are like
just barely connected to the overall
phenomena i want to know about the
synchronicities i want to know about the
owls i want to know about the weird
premonitions i want to know about the
psychic stuff that you know the core of
it
is the ufo contact experience i want to
know about all that outlying experiences
i want to explore that and it's elusive
all i can do i don't need proof i mean a
little bit
maybe some uh two witnesses see the same
thing maybe
um someone has a picture or a recording
and things like that so
um but so that that analogy
of bud hopkins who's
a pioneering researcher he wants to rein
it all in
i want to study the stuff at the outline
and that's what these books are it's all
the little speckles
that surround the core phenomena
so how did he hypnotize you
what was that how did you get how did
you get in touch with him
what made so he did you want to get
hypnotized or was he more interested in
hypnotizing you what
what brought this about so he so i
i i used to live in new york city so i
used to go back and forth to new york
city and visit folks a lot and stuff so
he was working
um in new york city and at the time i
was living there in new york city i
didn't have any interest in this at all
but that was so
i left new york city when i was about
30.
and then i was living out west and then
and then when i was when i was out west
in idaho was when i really started to
dig into this research and
uh dig into reading the books and
started eventually dig into my own
experiences and do my own research
but before i was doing my own research i
i guess i had started that was after the
thing with kristin
um the the events of seeing the multiple
owls
which isn't that interesting of a story
right we saw some owls while camping big
deal
but it changed the direction of my life
so um i sent him a letter
and he replied and i visited his house
and hit you know those laundry baskets
you get at the dollar store you know
they're like big plastic
laundry baskets he had that was just
like these files and they're all old
like these old
like dividers and one would say like you
know
uh close-up sighting one would say uh
missing time one would say
you know lights in the sky and and
there was just like letters and letters
and letters and i'm like i looked at
this big thing it's like is that from
last year
he went that's from last month
so i've talked to other ufo researchers
and i'll ask them like what's the
what what do you what's the proof in
this how do you find the proof in this
and i had one lady kind of roll her eyes
and go like look at my email inbox you
want proof that's the proof
like how like i'm flooded i'm like and
i'm nobody like i write this
this the owl research is way at the
outer edge and i'm getting
stories all the time i'm asking for them
and i'm getting them but
okay your question was what was it like
getting hypnotized by bus yeah so i call
i wrote him a letter
i got back to me and i was uh gonna be
in new york
and i went and visited him and it was a
year later that i went back
and visited him again and he said he was
basically like
you know hear their stories about the
beings in the yard and stuff like that
and
he was like like i was considering
hypnosis and i didn't want to do it so
this was your first time being
hypnotized
yeah and it didn't not much happened you
know what did happen so here the story i
told
initially did you go into like uh
no it's very it's very i've been
hypnotized i've gone to you know what i
did this is funny because this hypnosis
in the field like i'm on i'm this is
total inside baseball here where you're
like you're on the outside and i'm
trying to bring you up to speed and like
so like the infighting and the snipiness
and the pickering and the
the anger and the the butting heads
within the ufo research community
is like it's crazy how antagonistic
people can be towards each other
so within this that field like there are
people who hate
hate hate anything that has to do with
hypnosis by using hypnosis you're
introducing false data you're doing
right
you can implant false memories right
exactly right this you can make an
argument that and then on the other side
there's people who like oh
the only way to access the truth is
through hypnosis
and and so like i'm in the middle
somewhere
which is a better place to be i think
than to be like
a true believer either under that
spectrum and and so i'm super cautious
so
well all of all of the most famous
abduction stories all of the most famous
abductees like travis walt and
barney all they all have been hypnotized
right but travis walton
most of his recollection is conscious in
the books that i've written
most of the reports are like i'll say 99
of the reports are done with this almost
no hypnosis
uh used in my books a little bit and
they're my own hypnosis that i use in
in uh but he he's been walt travis has
been through hypnosis yeah since like
multiple times to re wrap
his yeah so yeah so and then if you read
buds books there's like this it seems
like
50 of the the data emerges through
hypnosis and what i'm finding is i don't
really i
like like i don't trust hypnosis in to
that degree where i think it's
like where it's the truth
emerging word for word i think it's a
mess like it gets complicated and
it's for sure so um but the hypnosis
hypnotherapists
will keep certain facts to themselves
you know like what was how was i i don't
give away too much but i mean there's
some things i know that i
i won't share but simple things like how
is the room lit this is actually someone
everyone knows like what do you mean
things that what kind of things okay so
like so like what does a doorknob look
like on a flying saucer like what's the
insignia on the suit um
uh you know what's the you know
is this the kind of stuff that you would
remember after hypnosis
under hypnosis you would you would say
these things that that that would be
consistent with other reports
an insignia on a suit uh you know what's
the doorknob look like on a flying
saucer like if you're on board a craft
um you know word for word
the the aliens will
tell an abductee the same thing
oftentimes it's very similar to what
they told the
the kids in zimbabwe you know
i'm paraphrasing roughly but your
spirituality has far
advanced excuse me your technology is
far
in advance of your spirituality and
you're in a dangerous place as human as
humans on earth
so you know hypnosis is like it's
bud was bud was very ill at the time he
hypnotized me
and i laid i was on his bed and there
was a woman in the room videotaping it
really and i had a blanket on me at the
videotape it's not that interesting
right so bud's like sitting there
talking very
softly and i'm like sitting not moving
and all talking very softly it's
incredibly boring to watch there's long
long long pauses how does he get you
into the state of hypnosis
it's pretty so it i mean it's just a
very
simple set of commands basically saying
relax
you know like simple things imagine
you're going down the stairs
every step you take you're in a deeper
state
um and and it doesn't feel that
different
it doesn't feel it feels like you know i
mean like you're lying in a bed you're
relaxed and then he'll ask you a
question you'll say stuff like why did i
say that
like where did that come from i'll i got
some stories to but
for for bud the only thing that came up
we
everything that we covered
was exactly the same in my
from my normal memory no my conscious
memory yeah no new information emerged
except for a few little things and one
of them was
the image of the five aliens in the yard
there was a palpable sense and i talked
about it
it was like it wasn't just oh yes
they're here it was almost like
oh [ __ ] they're back
it's them again
i had that thought under hypnosis
does now here's a question for you does
that make it true that i've been
abducted multiple times by these
great beings just because i had a
thought that said oh [ __ ] they're back
it's them again it's them and i remember
palpably feeling like this is so
familiar
this is so familiar seeing them out
there does that make it true
i don't have an answer for that i could
see being vulnerable and wanting it to
be true
and i could see being traumatized and
saying no i reject that
you know i'm trying to stay somewhere in
the middle
i